[Música]
y como se dan cuenta la presentación va
a estar en mi idioma natal así que todos
lo van a entender perfectamente la razón
que yo puse esto es es muy importante
porque cuando me pidieron hacer este
este con explicación no exponencia para
ustedes eso tiene algo que ver mucho
porque cada uno de nosotros tenemos una
historia y no hay nada mas inspiracional
de saber como uno tiene que trabajar
yo soy un nazi en 1958 tengo 60 años
de irán
tengo dos hijos uno de ellos es 27 años
de vigo millenials y otro de 17 de post
millenials y ustedes imaginan los baby
boomers lo que nacimos en estas épocas
somos la peor generación porque en esta
época cuando nosotros nacimos los padres
nos decían que tenemos que hacer que
tenemos que comer que tenemos que
estudiar hoy nuestros hijos dicen dónde
tenemos que ir a comer que tenemos que
comer y dónde tenemos que ir a
vacacionar y qué es lo que ellos quieren
estudiar entonces se lo imaginaron
entonces
lo que yo yo trato de explicarles
yo nací en irán soy hijo de un coronel
militar de fuerzas armadas de irán mi
madre
una estilista una de las primeras
mujeres que estudió ser estilista porque
en estas épocas de años 60 en mi país
las mujeres no tenían tanto derecho de
ni trabajar ni ni estudiar mucho sin
embargo ella se esforzó y lo estudió en
edad de seis años
mis padres se divorcian en mi madre se
casan nuevamente y nosotros en mi país
la custodia de
de los niños se van a los papás al papá
entonces vamos a vivir con él y en edad
de nueve años lamentablemente el 31 de
agosto de 1964
mi padre fallece en un temblor en
adición de varias otras personas de mi
familia
y ustedes pueden imaginar que uno como
un niño en esta edad se siente
es un consejo que le tengo que dar
porque a veces lo tomamos muy sencillo y
no aprovechamos y disfrutar nuestros
padres hasta nos damos cuenta cuando es
demasiado tarde entonces es un tema muy
muy importante poder aprovechar y
disfrutar sus papás de este momento
venimos a vivir con mis padres con mi
mamá y mi padrastro a mí me gustaría
referir a mi padrastro mi padre porque
la verdad tenemos una imagen del
padrastro pero el padre que yo tuve fue
extraordinario y gracias a él hoy estoy
donde estoy
inmediatamente el inicio de enfocarse en
mis estudios me puso a estudiar el sexto
grado en el verano está alto al
secundario en el secundario me esfuerzo
de estudiar inglés tres horas al día
lunes a viernes no lo entendía lo odiaba
sin embargo lo tuve que hacer en 74 me
manda a eeuu a estudiar y practicar el
inglés practicarlo 74 al 76 me porté muy
mal gaste todo el dinero que tenía me
fuerce a trabajar es el primera vez que
empecé a trabajar ilegalmente obviamente
como mozo de cocinas lavando platos de
11 de la noche a 7 de la mañana a las 9
iba a trabajar en la escuela
regreso a irán hago mi servicio militar
es obligatorio dos años tienes que hacer
servicio militar
después de esto que terminó el servicio
militar mientras yo estaba ahí mis
padres deciden de emigrar se a eeuu y
ellos se van y yo me quedo atrás así
terminando mi servicio militar terminó
el servicio lamentablemente en esta
época
las relaciones entre irán y eeuu fueron
fatales tuvieron los bienes de d
d
algunos han visto la película árbol los
rehenes de la embajada y de ahí ya todos
los países no nos aceptaban y el único
país que nos aceptaba en este momento de
la embajada de eeuu fue españa y la
única forma que tú podías llegar a eeuu
era a través de ayuda humanitaria o
causas humanitarias y por casualidad yo
vivía con mi tía y mi tía tenía que
hacer una operación de corazón abierta
que en esta época no se llevaba a cabo
en irán
tomamos la decisión compramos nuestros
boletos hacemos nuestro cita en la
embajada de eeuu en madrid yo vuelo a
madrid fue 18 o 19 de septiembre de 1980
llegó ahí preparó todo listo para irnos
dos días después estalla la guerra entre
irán e irak
mi tía nunca sale de irán
estoy varado en españa'
en madrid no hablo
no hablo absolutamente nada de español
lo único que hablaba un poco de inglés
con 800 dólares en el bolsillo
no podía regresar a irán porque me
llevaban a la guerra y no podía irme a
estados unidos entonces tenía que
sobrevivir unos dos o tres años en
madrid un día caminando en la calle
porque el dinero vuela en europa no no
es nada fácil vivir ahí de un hotel que
estuvimos fuimos a un hostal donde
estábamos 50 personas en en camastros
durmiendo juntos
en la calle veo un anuncio que aceptan
profesores de inglés buscan profesores
de inglés entro a esta agencia me hacen
el examen obviamente pasó y empieza a
dar clases de inglés a los empresarios
cobrando dos dólares por hora
afortunadamente caigo muy bien a los
empresarios preguntan hoy en cuánto te
paga la agencia de 12 dólares tiene un
perfecto te contratamos 10 dólares tú
por ahora y así empecé fíjense el inglés
que odiaba de mis padres que me estaban
forzando a aprender me salvó la vida
digo estoy en españa porque no aprende
el español me describí y empecé a
aprender español y este mismo español
gracias a este idioma me tiene hoy en
día en frente de ustedes
en 1982
mi residencia de eeuu se cumple empiezo
trabajando forzar forzosamente porque yo
quería estudiar ya había terminado la
prepa sin embargo la circunstancia de la
vida mi padre había perdido todo mi
madre estaba trabajando junto con mi
hermana y empecé a ayudarles a trabajar
no no no seguí estudiando y él lo
lamento muchísimo empezó a trabajar en
los hoteles
como mesero y de ahí empecé a subir
mesero como gerente de restaurante
gerente de restaurante gerente de
alimentos si vivieras director de
alimentos y bebidas como mencionan
trabajé en cinco países y en 1996 cuando
estaba moviendo mi vida de un hotelero
es como un gitano tú nunca estás en una
ciudad más de un año o dos años entonces
no puedes establecerte en ningún lugar
entonces me ofrecen y dicen que
lamentable que no habla español digo
pues yo hablo un poquito de español y
viví en españa dos años ahí me mandan
por 90 días a isla navidad ustedes
pueden imaginar no sé si quienes han
viajado a manzanillo al aeropuerto
cuando entras al aeropuerto y sales y
dices que hice dios mío qué decisión fue
esto pero este fue un parte muy
importante parte agua es muy importante
para mí porque de ahí fui a venezuela
estuve ahí dos años me casé nuevamente y
regresé
a méxico en 1999 para dirigir los
hoteles princess y pierre márquez de ahí
me dieron la oportunidad de irme aymara
tos árabes abrir un hotel extraordinario
para el príncipe de mar a tos árabes
después de ahí vine a méxico nuevamente
y y un tema muy importante era
en mil en 2006 tuve la oportunidad de
conocer juan antonio hernández venegas
el presidente del grupo autofin y mundo
imperial
me convenció de unirme con un grupo
mundo imperial yo para mí acapulco me ha
dado mucho lo de verdad lo considero mi
tierra hoy soy ciudadano mexicano
aparte que soy ciudadano americano pero
esto para mí es para mi país y regreso a
baja ciudad a eeuu y siempre la
inmigración me dice que es eso tiene
ciudadanía y vienes a vacacionar aquí
porque me gusta méxico y siempre pensé
que este proyecto del mundo imperial
puede dar una vida nueva
acapulco y siempre he dicho hay un mundo
acapulco antes del mundo imperial y hay
otro después del mundo imperial
en 2009 enfrentamos una crisis muy
fuerte tenemos que despedir mucha gente
viene el crisis financiero automotriz
tiene influencia viernes guerra contra
el narco el famoso director general se
convierte a un velador y despedir 300
400 personas que habíamos elegido dentro
del 5000 extraordinario colaboradores
sin embargo uno tiene que levantarse uno
tiene que levantarse y tener la
perseverancia y ahí es donde era un tema
importante
d
aunque yo no me he ido a estudiar en
universidad siempre trate de prepararme
y siempre trate de estudiar y el tema
era que usted no llega a ser un director
general si no sabe de finanzas y no sabe
de comercialización si no sabe de
mercadotecnia si no sabe de
administración de empresas entonces
siempre tienes que prepararte cuando
nuestro proyecto termino mi propietario
me comentó un día tú eres un gran
hotelero pero no eres un buen empresario
esto me dolió muchísimo y le dije está
bien para mí el único empresario es
usted yo soy un hotelero y yo soy un
colaborador sin embargo esto me quedó
grabado y decidí de irme a buscar la
mejor escuela de negocios y elegí para
de el equipo de en este momento tomé un
envío de un año tuve la oportunidad de
estar en una curso de alta dirección con
unos 80 90 extraordinarios empresarios
que me han ayudado mucho
fortalecer me
en esto
y siempre mi padre me decía que el
conocimiento y el estudio son muy
importantes para uno y yo les recomiendo
esto muchísimo nunca dejen de prepararse
ustedes son el futuro de este país y
vivimos en un mundo
sumamente
extraño y quiero compartir estas cosas
con ustedes porque para mí ha habido
mucha gente que yo ni siquiera me lo
imaginaba fueron una gran influencia en
mi vida mi padre mi madre un ejemplo mi
padre en edad de 50 años cuando perdió
todas las inversiones que tenía en eeuu
empezó a estudiar informática en eeuu y
mi madre igual tiene 84 años el día de
hoy y sigue trabajando un día a la
semana porque esto lo mantiene vivo
entonces son temas muy muy importantes y
para conclusiones quiero decirles que
muchas veces aprendemos por dolor y no
por conciencia
la vida me esfuerzo
y aprender muchas cosas y hacer muchas
cosas
de verdad de verdad es muy difícil poder
explicar todos los momentos que uno
tiene sentando pensando diciendo que
hago que no hago cuando eres 18 años 19
años 20 años 24 años es cada momento
tiene su su tema en la vida nada viene
gratis esto tengan seguro la
perseverancia y el esfuerzo hacia la
diferencia por favor graben lo mucho hay
que prepararse y actualizarse siempre
vivimos en un mundo muy competitivo
muy diferente siempre lo digo a mis
hijos hijo yo tenía prepa a mi tiempo no
no me dio sin embargo yo tengo la
universidad de la vida a ti te va a
tocar prepararte y una licenciatura o
cuatro años de estudios no es suficiente
el día de hoy si no tengan una maestría
si no tengan dos tipos de títulos no les
sirve tengan paciencia en su momento y
llegará no salga nada de universidad y
quieren comer el mundo muchos yo ahorita
entrevistó muchas gentes que salen de
escuelas de hotelería y quieren ser
gerente general
yo los contrató gerente de restaurante o
gerente de botones porque si quieres ser
un buen gerente tienes que saber
exactamente todas las posiciones porque
nunca debes pedir a alguien que haga
algo que tú no estás dispuesto de hacer
muy muy importante
el último el único lugar donde el éxito
está antes del trabajo es en el
diccionario gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]